- [Instructor] We are
asked what is the height
of the sunflower?
So pause this video and think about it.
All right, so let's see.
The bottom of the
sunflower is right aligned
with the bottom of the ruler,
so there ruler's in the right place.
And let's see, the sunflower goes
all the way up to this
point right over here.
So this is one, two, three, four, five,
and then a little bit more.
So we're going to get into a fraction.
So what is this extra amount?
So if we can see the space between five
and six is divided into
four equal sections.
So we have, one, two, three, four.
Or we could see it here.
They've divided it with
these little hash marks
into one, two, three, four equal sections.
And this goes one of
those four equal sections
towards six, so this is 5 1/4 feet.
That's how tall the sunflower is.
All right, let's do another example.
So here we are told, or we are asked,
which pencil measures 2 3/4 of an inch?
So pause this video and
try to think about it.
All right, so we go one inch, two inches,
and then we have to think about how far
between two and three is 3/4?
So to think about 3/4, we have
to divide the part, or
the part of this ruler,
between two and three
into four equal sections.
So let's see.
If I were to just split it like this,
that's two equal sections.
So if I were to take each
of those two equals sections
and then split them, now
that's four equal sections.
Notice one, two, three,
four equal sections.
So when we're thinking about 3/4,
we wanna go three of
those four equal sections.
One, two, three.
And so you can see right over here,
that is 2 3/4.
This is 2 3/4 right over here.
And that is pencil A.